well that's that's like because i think  i think it's not about like you  especially if you have a family it's not  about you anymore like doesn't she leave  does she leave a husband and kids and  eat pray love  uh she needs a husband  my husband did a job yeah like i don't  know i think that's that's a bit selfish  you're leaving a commitment you made for  what to go like go to india but to be  selfish means that we're prioritizing  what everyone else wants compared to  what we want yeah but sometimes what you  want isn't right like emotions come and  go people leave that's it right and  wrong very subjective there's it's all  about that gray area walking the middle  path right and wrong to one person so  that's it genocide and racism to one  person is right